today I'm going to get my advice for a
nine-year-old Evan
[Music]
what's up believe nation happy sunday
hope you had an amazing weekend so I
have a quick little story to share and
then some advice where my sister
stephanie has a co-worker who has a son
named Evan and he's nine years old and
he decided that once he heard about me
he wanted to create this sign here he
painted this it's a it's a legit
painting and he painted it and he put
Evan on it and he puts circles and
sparkles and all sorts of fun stuff in
here so I appreciate the love Evan and
Evans goal is to be a millionaire he's
nine years old and he feels like the
only way to do it is to be an actor so I
thought I might hear some perspective on
that first of all I love the name dude
that's a fantastic name I think
everybody should have amazing names like
that and listen there's a lot of ways
that you can become a millionaire make
lots of money but let me tell you if you
want to be a huge financial success
don't make money your main goal this is
my office where I do most of my work see
that man behind me he's name is Steve
Jobs just start a company called apple
and he became one of the richest people
in the world he built his company to be
one of the he built somebody do the most
valuable company in the world he was a
millionaire in his 20s and he kept
working harder and working harder and
working harder and the goal for him was
never the money the goal was never just
to have tons of cash the goal was to do
something important the goal is to do
something he loved and so there's a lot
of different ways to go out and have
financial success you don't have to do
it by being an actor you could be an
entrepreneur you can be you can be an
actor you can be a musician you can be
an inventor you can be whatever you want
to be if you want to be able to make a
lot of money it's going to come from
providing people with a ton
value and that only comes from by doing
the thing that you're passionate about
there's a lot of people who want to be
an actor because they want to make a lot
of money and they never make it they
never get the big roles they never make
that a lot of money because acting was
never really the thing that they love
doing they were just trying to do it to
get to that financial success and if
that's where you're at then you're not
going to make it as a successful actor
you have to love acting you have to act
because you want to act you have to wake
up and want to be an active today I want
to be an actor the next day and want to
watch other actors and get their advice
and get their lessons and pour that into
yourself to be the best actor you can be
and if you can do that if you can be an
amazing actor then you'll make a lot of
money we're the same thing for being an
entrepreneur running your own business
if you start a business just trying to
make a lot of money you're never going
to make it but if you start a business
because you love the product that you're
making because you really want to help
people then you're going to be able to
provide insane value and you're going to
be able to build a successful company
and make a lot of money and so I would
encourage you not to have money as your
main goal as a nine-year-old Evan
watching this I would encourage you not
to make money your primary goal I would
encourage you to think about what it is
that you love doing what do you wish you
could do all day long and then how can
you translate that into something that
can help other people when you can
combine what you love doing with
something that really helps somebody
else that's your path to becoming a
millionaire so Evan I hope you're
watching this great name again thank you
for the amazing piece of art I'm humbled
and honored and I hope you take the
advice man let me know what you think
thank you guys so much for watching if
you have advice for the nine year old
Evan who wants to be a millionaire actor
leave it down the comments below chances
are he's gonna read it or at least his
mom is going to I believe in you guys I
would continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is
much love as he seen